في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قالت
سلطات ومقاطعه زبالوجيا الاوكرانيه ان
الروس شنوا اكثر من 100 هجوم خلال الساعات
الماضيه على نحو سته عشره منطقه وبلده
واقعه تحت واقعه تحت السيطره الجيش
الاوكراني في المقاطعه الجنوبيه اضافه ان
القصف تم بقذائف المدفعيه ومسيرات وصواريخ
جراد واستهدف مناطق سكنيه وشبكات خدمات
عامه واوقع عددا من الجرحى قال حاكم خرسون
الاوكرانيين للقوات الروسيه قصفت المقاطعه
الجنوبيه اكثر من 70 مره واطلقت اكثر من
400 قذيفه على المناطق المدنيه والبنيه
التحتيه خلال 24 ساعه وفي مقاطعه
اعلنت الاداره الاوكرانيه استمرار القصف
الروسي على المناطق الساحليه وريف
المقاطعه الجنوبيه اكدت استمرار القصف على
المناطق المائيه في منطقه اوتشاكوف
واوضح الجيش الاوكراني ان الروسي يواصلون
الدفاع عن مواقعهم على طول الضفه الشرقيه
من نهر دينيبر في خرسون واضاف ان المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه الثقيله تواصل قصف تمركز
الافراد والعتاد الروسي في تلك الضفه